foreign
stories of 2022 we're each taking a look
at the top headlines from the past year
Jesse you go first war in Ukraine just
dominated the spring season we covered
it wall-to-wall here on Fox News Channel
you haven't seen tanks in the European
theater like that for decades really
shocked the country shocked the world
that you would see that type of
brutality again in that part of the
world the stock market took a hit uh
Energy prices were affected Supply
chains food prices it's really scrambled
the entire European energy policy and
we're still feeling the repercussions of
it and it's a cold winter it's going to
continue uh could continue for years you
never know how it's going to play out
but this was The Story of the Year
according to Jesse Waters okay Dana well
I agree on certainly on Ukraine and the
ramifications of that are going to
continue through 2023. um as is the
story that I chose which is the one on
the border the southern border just a
couple of points here
in all of 2020
there were 458 000 encounters at the
border we are two and a half months in
to fiscal year 2023 and they're already
505 thousand that's not counting 140 000
gotaways Fox News has covered the story
every single day it is astounding to me
how every morning on America's Newsroom
we can turn to Bill malusion or Griff
Jenkins or Nate Foy whoever's down on
the border for us and you can see oh
Dana Bill 300 migrants just came across
and it's you know it's Daybreak over
here in Eagle Pass Texas or Del Rio it's
also happening in Arizona New Mexico and
California and this is also not just
bringing immigrants who are illegally
entering the country they now are
Fanning out across the country so every
state every locality is affected by it
every school every hospital and there's
no end in sight and we are about to have
a big change in this country as you see
some of the protections and reasons that
we could turn away migrants as being
blocked by courts that would be title 42
which was the public health issue so now
you are looking at having thousands of
migrants every day coming into the
country are I've never been somebody
who's like oh we're for open borders to
me it feels like the border is totally
open and I'm just shocked that you have
a commander-in-chief who has turned a
blind eye to it and just think about
this anybody who traveled over the
holidays or if you have plans in the
future you're going to go through TSA
you're going to have to take off your
belt take off your shoes put your stuff
through security and why do we do that
to keep us all safe and we this is an
agreement we have all made and we might
think it's really annoying but we all do
it there were 98 people caught last year
that were on the terrorist watch list
those are the ones that we caught at the
border with a million gotaways all said
how many else how many others are there
and we're not doing enough to protect
this country not only from all the
problems that it could lead to
in regards to your social structure but
also I think the worry is on from a
national security perspective and as
Jesse pointed out earlier in the month
we have a situation with a narco State
on our Southern border this is a huge
story and what's shocking is that there
is not more reporters willing to cover
it you know what it is a huge story Dana
and the craziest part of it is that we
have basically lost our sovereignty as a
nation we are no longer a Sovereign
Nation we are nothing more than a global
landing spot for anyone who wants to
come here and you know just last week I
was listening and there was something
like in one week people from 96
different countries arrived in the in
you know through the border illegally
and uh but but Tyrus what's your take on
the board on what day is talking about
well the Border I think has also been
I'm using the term it's like a Gateway
for what we're seeing a ripple down
effect across the country because it
leads to so many other things now I'm
not saying that everyone who crosses the
border the Danish point is a criminal or
a terrorist but it does lead because
that border also we have all the
fentanyl coming in so we're creating
more problems for our residents it's in
the neighborhoods that are directly next
to the Border are overwhelmed the cities
and towns are overwhelmed with no help
in sight Jessica the sad part about it
is now that so many people are coming
through with a you know with title 42
basically being eliminated we're hearing
about people who are sleeping on the
streets where they're not enough beds
it's cold in Texas right now right and I
mean the humanitarian way to handle it
would be to at least create some kind of
safety net for them well that's what
happened before the numbers skyrocketed
to these levels there was this push to
build enough facilities and then we
found out that 1500 beds aren't enough
because you're getting 3 000 people in
item what are you to do about that and
he used exactly the right word
humanitarian so whatever kind of Crisis
you want to have if you want to have a
national security crisis that's fine if
that's how Republicans want to talk
about it but Democrats if you want to
talk about it from the human level
that's just as important as what's going
on in the National Security side because
there are people who are becoming
homeless there are people who are being
raped coming across here people who are
selling their children there are people
just flat out dying making this very
very dangerous Journey so until then
Jesse why is the administration not
addressing the issues that Jessica's
talking about well it's part strategy
part incompetence they wanted to do the
exact opposite of what Trump did and
they want cheap labor for their donors
and they also want new voters
and they want people to come here and
have babies that's what AOC and Schumer
said all part of a plan so they're
either executing the plan or they don't
know what they're doing either way it's
not good it isn't anyway on to
my story of the year my story of the
year has to do with Elon Musk exposing
Twitter I think this is the biggest
story of the year because for centuries
As Americans uh in fact this country was
founded on the concept of free speech
the First Amendment the ability to say
what you want and that first amendment
doesn't just address you and I speaking
IT addresses the power of the press and
the ability of the press to not suffer
from prior uh constraints and what we
had in America and what we saw as a
result of Elon Musk exposing what was
going on at Twitter was that there was
prior restraint there was suppression of
free speech there was suppression not
only of Free Speech but oppression in
One Direction so that there would be an
election impacted in one particular way
and not both ways and I think that this
chilling censorship indicates to me the
end of a democracy just as with the
Border we are now no longer a Sovereign
Nation but a globalist landing spot with
Benefits we now have a a press that is
not being that is not holding up its
part of the deal as the fourth estate
that all of us as Americans relied on to
kind of check what government was doing
to be that fourth estate it's not
happening anymore and when the head of
Twitter was called before Congress he
lied he lied under oath now he can say
right no oh I didn't know what was going
on at my own company hogwash you knew
Jack Dorsey why you were called before
Congress you knew the issue had to do
with Hunter Biden and you knew that
there was you know 51 officials
intelligence officials who said it
looked like Intel uh like Russian
disinformation so you knew there was an
issue there that you had to address
before you went to Congress but no you
put your hand down you swore to tell the
truth and you lied and so the search
results being manipulated that affected
a federal election the end of the First
Amendment to me is one of the biggest
stories not only of 2022 but of the
century so far what say you Jesse I
agree and in 10 years we may even see
this being bigger because things are
still coming out and Elon confessed he
said I'm here to save democracy I'm here
to save free speech and the fact that he
plowed what 44 billion into this thing
and then just kind of wrestled it away
from the grip of the FBI the CIA the
Democratic National Committee shows you
how fast we were veering towards not the
Republic that we know and love and
thank you to Elon Musk for doing that
everybody owes this guy a big debt of
gratitude yep I couldn't agree more Dana
what's your take on well I think that we
were in this middle if you look back in
history at New Year's is a good time to
do that and you think back not only to
just the past year but just as in the
scope of things to come I think when the
history books are written people will
look back at this period and say social
media had been given this free reign for
a while because nobody knew what it was
going to be like and then it turns out
to be something that we realize oh gosh
that's not very good in fact it's
actually destroying well leading to
destruction of some parts of our
democracy and so Elon Musk takes a pin
and bursts the balloon and now we can
all have a chance to regroup and I think
in the next year you might see some
attempts by Congress to do something
about it however Congress is always
behind the times when it comes to
technology and the private sector will
just have creative destruction and
create something new and that's
something that Elon Musk is doing all
right Tyrus your reaction woke martyrdom
that's what it's that's what they're
going to say it was it was it wasn't
about Hunter Biden it was always one one
thing the mission was simple you have to
stop president Trump for whatever reason
all the things that he was going to
drain the swamp he did not realize how
deep the swamp was and how many monsters
were in it and they came out and their
whole thing no matter how they look at
yes we use the FBI yes we but we did it
our greater good was we had to stop
president Trump and we saw the entire
time and it worked so you will not see
any oh I'm sorry you will not see any of
that and these they weren't necessarily
Democrats these are just this woke group
that has decided what the country needs
because they virtue signal they know
what's best even though it wasn't for
the best and we're seeing the results of
that so
um it it will be always be called the
woke martyrdom but when you look back at
this at 10 years president Trump I think
the light is going to be very different
on him based off all the evidence we're
starting to see all right Jessica your
big story for 2022. so my big story was
the red wave that wasn't or maybe Joe
Biden isn't that
how I call it so I think there are three
main takeaways from the midterm results
and and we all know that we're just
constantly in campaign mode and what did
we get off you know a few days before we
started going into what's going to
happen in 2024 but there were some
pretty big lessons from it so the first
sorry reference maybe Joe Biden isn't
that bad maybe and Jesse I thought one
of the points you made a couple months
ago was really Salient which is people
just don't hate him the way that they
hate others you do try and sometimes you
succeed
um I know but it's a really important
point that he doesn't raise this level
of ire or animosity as a Hillary or a
Barack Obama and we can talk about why
that may be I think most people
understand certainly why I think that is
so Joe Biden had the most successful
midterm since the 1930s it's a really
big deal so there's a house majority for
the Republicans very slight Kevin
McCarthy not being able to Corral the
caucus as he expected
um so that's a really interesting aspect
of it the two other things that I think
are important out of the midterm results
first of all the importance of the issue
of abortion that the Dobbs ruling may
not have been the gift for Republicans
that they thought that it was and I
understand that for a lot of uh pro-life
activists that this is the long game
right that it's not about winning an
election today or in two years four
years whatever it is it's about
protecting life
um and the way that they see it but
people showed up Democrats a lot of
Republicans a lot of moderates and said
that what's going on in very
conservative States is unacceptable
you'll see a lot more of these
referendums like in Kansas and Kentucky
and Michigan and you had Jim Messina on
America's Newsroom uh right after where
he said yeah we're gonna run the table
on this and make sure that everyone
votes on it the third Point that's
important Donald Trump's impact on the
midterms was terrible just like it was
in 2020
um lost the Senate again as a result of
hand-picked candidates that he thought
were great
um and that ended up being really
terrible and I know that he's declared
to run for president but right now it
looks like a campaign and name only and
he's losing a lot of salience in the
party Happy New Year yeah oh I'm sorry
the Border is open we have no free
speech yeah all right Democrats one
what's your big story
crime and homelessness and I think they
go hand in hand we've seen more videos
this year of just Americans just being
awful to each other and little or no
consequences the no cash bail has hurt a
lot of families destroyed businesses and
again this is where I talked about the
Border fentanyl coming in Fentanyl and
meth are now the two leading causes of
homelessness in this country those
numbers have like almost doubled
probably by the time in a few months
from now they'll triple because people
and no there's no help there's no media
attention to it we don't see it China
manufactures it they send it to they
send it to Mexico to be made and then it
comes to America and kills our kids and
the ones who aren't being killed by it
they end up so strung out and we see the
zombies walking the streets and everyone
doesn't do it's not until Unfortunately
they die that somebody cares enough to
talk about no one's making the effort
the media is not interested in it I I am
one of the things I'm very proud about
being a Fox News contributors that we
did talk about it we kept bringing it up
and it needs to be and it's very simple
you have to cut the snake's head off and
where do you do that one you pick up the
phone and you tell trying to stop
sending that stuff too
I know Gutfeld likes to bomb things I
like to Target things you can drop
little in Spanish waivers all over these
little factories where they make this
stuff and let them know that a missiles
coming your way on this day where you
can blow up these spot these are
terrorists if these were in Iraq or
these were in Afghanistan they were
making these plants and sending it over
here we would do something about it so
something needs to be done but I'm glad
at least they're getting a voice here
because this story should have been the
top story because who are the victims
are American citizens and our kids and
there's just not enough voices for them
yeah great great segment
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight